janis joplin et tant que pôle gaye et
est possédé et les grateful dead
semblait être bien vivant lors du
festival express un événement musical
qui a défrayé les manchettes à l'été
1970 on n'avait jamais vu ça
les promoteurs avait nolisé un train
pour permettre à tous les artistes
invités de voyager ensemble de toronto à
calgary en passant par winnipeg
malgré la liste des têtes d'affiché qui
était impressionnante dès le début
l'événement semble déraillé car lors du
premier concert à toronto des centaines
de manifestants ne veulent pas payer le
prix du billet soit 14 dollars il exige
que le festival soit gratuit la police
s'en mêle
malgré tout près de 37 personnes
assistent à l'événement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais dans le train les musiciens
s'amusent c'est la fête
jour et nuit entre deux spectacles ont
feu et on boit beaucoup
les réserves ont été vite écoulée et on
a dû arrêter la locomotive d'urgence à
saskatoon pour acheter pour près de 800
$ d'alcool un magnifique tir tout
simplement baptisé festival express
retrace ce périple de trois concerts qui
au final s'est avéré une catastrophe
financière à cause des manifestations
pendant cette semaine de musique sur
scène et d'un train près de 500 mille
dollars ont été perdus dans l'opération
mais aujourd'hui tous ceux et celles qui
étaient à bord de ce train dont robert
charlebois se console avec toutes ces
images retrouvées
on peut y voir la fin d'une époque
mais surtout un des derniers tours de
chant deux derniers jort le décès des
trois mois après ce festival express
wahaha
bbc louis fait des primaires radio
canada montréal
[Musique]